Congrats on the first half of season
four Morty
thanks Matt Pat glad you liked it it's a
show that you know takes a lot of
brainpower to understand I know we have
to do another theory on your show oh
geez Matt Pat haven't you done enough of
those already it really seems like
you're milking our franchise for cheap
YouTube views tell me again how many
episodes season four has turn and how
many multi week breaks have you taken
during the rollout of those 10 episodes
well we're on number three right now so
tell me again who's really milking this
show for the views fill you hello
internet welcome to film Theory the show
where we explore all of the infinite
realities and at this point I've made a
theory about most of them you know I've
really enjoyed doing individual episode
breakdowns of Rick and Morty this season
I guess you could call it Matt Pat
selfish content I did it because you
know what I just really wanted to talk
about this show with someone other than
Stephanie all the time and luckily you
all seem to enjoy those little fast
turnaround mini Theory episodes too
which was great
I would expect to see probably a couple
more of those show up when the second
half of the season drops that said this
is not one of those theories where I
spend a lot of time breaking down an
individual episode or an individual
character or specific moment this theory
is about season four of Rick and Morty
as a whole where the second half of the
season and beyond goes from here because
more so than in past seasons there seems
to have been a lot of disgruntled Rick
and Morty fans out there talking about
how this has been a disjointed season
one without a whole lot of focus no real
themes to latch on to nothing deep being
explored and a parade of toilet humor
shrimp piling the Third Reich and like
snakes a surprisingly large amount of
snakes as the user dr. Lecter put it on
reddit quote in season four were not
really seeing those family dynamics
anymore now the premise is just
fanservice cheap laughs insane antics
with no grounding and furthering the
plot or the premise of the show end
quote and I use that quote as an example
but it's really indicative of a lot of
the conversation I've been seeing around
this season at the show but is that
really true what is the point of season
four is there a point
I mean sure in earlier seasons the
through lines were a lot easier to
follow season one turned sci-fi tropes
on their head by showing that when you
fix a problem with sci-fi magic you
actually create disasters you wish your
dog talked if he could he'd enslave
you want to shrink down to explore the
human body too bad you're gonna blow up
a giant floating homeless Santa in the
process you want a hot girl to fall in
love with you well spoiler alert she's
gonna turn into a praying mantis and try
to eat your head thereby necessitating
you to abandon your entire dimension in
season two we start to get real glimpses
of just how powerful rick is but also
the rampant wake of destruction that he
leaves behind rick fractures time he
offends peaceful planets he enslaves
aliens to power a ship's battery he
sells weapons to assassins and gets most
of his friends killed by the end of
those 10 episodes
fast forward to season 3 and we see how
the damage that Rick causes isn't just
on a galactic scale but also on a
personal one specifically with the Smith
family it's an unhealthy relationship
that exists between him and his daughter
Beth has massive ripple effects
throughout the season as it prompts Beth
to leave Jerry resulting in the kids
struggling with the separation and Rick
ultimately not being able to provide the
emotional support that any of them
really need I turned myself into a
pickle morty boom big reveal I'm a
pickle until finally they've had enough
and Rick is forced to return hat in hand
specifically fishing hat in hand I'm
fly-fishing Rick no not every single
episode necessarily plays into these
themes but overall rick and morty
seasons do indeed have arcs which means
that in theory season four should be no
exception so what is the art here and if
there is one What's it saying about the
narrative arc of these characters what
can we expect when the series returns
whenever it decides to return which
apparently according my Google News
Alerts was supposedly January 12 then
January 1926 seriously it got me excited
each and every week seems like a lot of
websites are worse at predicting things
than even I am and that is saying a lot
that said no in my track record I'm sure
that's sometime between me writing this
episode and me hitting publish on this
video we're gonna get a trailer that
directly contradicts everything I'm
about to say in this theory so whatever
selfish Content activate in case you
need a little refresher on Rick and
Morty season four here's the best recap
of the five episodes we've gotten so far
episode 1 rick and morty harvests some
death crystals that show the user
exactly how they're gonna die and when
morty sees a version of him dying with
jessica by his side he makes every
decision from then on to preserve that
future causing a lot of carnage on the
way Maury
a bunch of us girls were gonna go
skinny-dipping later if you wanted to
join No
I must continue moving in ways that lead
to dying with you
meanwhile Rick gets himself killed but
keeps on getting resurrected into
various clone forms trying to get back
to his original reality many of these
realities are dominated by fascist
animals but Rick is eventually helped by
the wasp a version of himself to get
home we're all in this together
wasps monsters episode 2 Jerry makes an
app so we don't know this one's gonna
play out what are you guys doing did you
develop an app in an episode concept to
rip straight out of lag mirror we watch
the world tear itself apart using
Jerry's date finding app love finders
which tells people who their soul mates
are gonna be but changes that match
constantly meanwhile Rick goes on a hunt
for revenge to punish the man who used
his super secret secluded toilet what
begins as a quest for bloody vengeance
becomes a budding friendship when Rick
learns about the premature death of the
man's wife a friendship that itself is
unfortunately cut off prematurely when
the Phantom Cooper meets a tragic skiing
accident episode 3 we get ourselves an
inception level placement scheme with
Rick building machine to randomize heist
plans only to demonstrate how
nonsensical and formulaic they are well
done Rando end of the episode we get
ourselves the big twist the root goal of
Rick's complex heist plans was in itself
a complex plan to sour Morty on the
concept of heist
since Morty have been working on a heist
screenplay that may have gotten him a
deal with Netflix and thereby prevented
him from going on future adventures is
probably best ignores one of the oddest
Rick and Morty episodes to date which is
a lot for a show that once turned a
character into a pickle Marty gets
himself a dragon who ultimately soul
bonds more strongly with Rick thereby
leading us down a rabbit hole of dragon
depravity also Jerry goes to Florida
with a talking cat that's presumably
more depraved than even the dragon so we
never really learned what the cat's deal
is and in episode 5 Marty gets bitten by
a space snake which he subsequently
kills and feel guilty about did him
descend an earth snake back to the
snakes home planet with a snake planet
realizes that they aren't alone in this
you
verse they invent time and space travel
to attempt to take over the earth
forcing Rick and Morty to do some
Terminator style time travel to kill the
snake ancestors and prevent their
dominance give them proof that there was
something bigger and scarier to unite
against you little idiot they dedicated
themselves into making universe
destroying unthought out technology like
time travel now that all might seem
random and disconnected and honestly it
is even as I sit here writing and
recording the episode it's like high
fantasy - snakes - death crystals -
heist plans a weird mix of episodes but
when you actually take a step back away
from looking at individual episode plots
it all points to one common theme which
is ironic because the theme is about the
fact that life is just a series of
random events let me explain each of
these episodes deals with the idea of
fate and whether or not destiny actually
exists spoiler alert the show concludes
the answer to be no but let's look at
each episode to figure out how I came to
that conclusion episode 1 is pretty darn
on-the-nose rick and morty pick up death
crystals that show you how you're gonna
die if you focus on following one
extremely specific path or another
throughout your whole life you're
guaranteed to know how you're gonna kick
the bucket it's like literally holding
your fate in the palm of your hands or
is it as the episode unfolds morty
blindly follows the directions of the
crystal in order to control the one
thing about his life how it ends in the
meantime he's completely lost control of
everything else down to the direction
that he can walk down the halls in
school and even then as the end gag
reveals Morty's perceived death wasn't
gonna play out the way that he expected
it to i want to comfort the people who
are dying who have no one else in their
lives
the real lonely people what this in turn
serves as our thesis statement for the
rest of the season if you try to control
your destiny you'll lose control of
pretty much everything else this whole
idea is underscored by Rick's plot in
this episode where he hops across
infinite universes and infinite versions
of themselves we're reminded that there
are really infinite realities a pressing
number of which are fascist and the idea
of following your one true destiny is
laughable in the face of an infinite
multiverse to show us just how futile
the idea of control is we get this
example
towards the end of the episode here a
holographic version of Rick who has been
powerless to do anything to control his
own fate for the entire episode finally
gains a physical body for the first time
the first thing he does celebrate how
powerful he is he can suddenly control
everyone around him he is all-powerful
he can move objects he's immediately
killed by the wasp a version of Rick
from another universe punctuating the
idea that one wasp stings are just
totally terrifying no matter what
universe you're in and - as soon as you
think you're in control of things you're
toast
there's a lesson here and I'm not the
one that's gonna figure it out don't
worry Rick I'm doing this one for you
though - lightens things up a bit with
that fun romp through dating apps and
destiny go figure
love finders is an app that supposedly
predicts your soulmate everyone on earth
desperate to find answers in their own
confusing lives immediately latches on
to this idea showing that everyone is
just looking for this elusive idea of
their destiny finding their one true
love the person they are fated to be
with because well that would mean that
there's a plan for everyone's life the
problem is that people's soulmates keep
changing ultimately ending up being
random because there's no such thing as
a soul mate and by proxy there's no such
thing as destiny life is random
sometimes you end up with the winner and
sometimes you're attracted to a guy
whose only future is as a telemarketer
for diet supplements on the off chance
that you use the app and there's someone
out there waiting for you sorry I didn't
use it did you me know we also learn a
little bit more about how this destiny
business applies to Rick in his bathroom
habits over in his swamp life Rick's
remote shy pooping habits are a
desperate bid for control in a universe
where he feels out of control you need
the same thing I needed Rick you know
what shy pooping is Rick it's a
pointless bid for control you want to
take the one part of life that you truly
think is yours and you want to protect
it from a universe that takes whatever
it wants it took my wife it clearly took
something from you we can spend our
lives fighting that but we can choose to
be free Rick know is probably better
than most that the universe is random
but has always thought that just maybe
if he's smart
he can control it the thing is his
fixation on control ruins everything
else in his life just like Morty
controlling his fate ruined Morty's life
in Episode one Rick is desperately
lonely he can't even connect with other
people like Tony who he has a lot in
common with and instead he spends most
of his time sabotaging the people and
relationships around him for wrecked
relationships present elements that he
can't control like emotional
vulnerability loss obligation so keeping
these things at distance is the best way
to control his own fate interestingly
enough this episode also presents what
could have been a lesson for Rick
towards the end of the episode Tony
decides to not let his need to control
things rule his life anymore and instead
he sets out to do the things that he
loves to do that he's been too afraid to
do this could have been an example for
Rick about how great life can be when
you just let go of control but it's not
because Tony dies anyways just wanted to
drop these off and you tell him the
toilets all his Tony died he quit his
job started living life to the fullest
he crashed into a tree space skiing down
mountain space ever is because the
universe is random and letting go of
control doesn't give you any more
control over whether or not you live or
die
CSUN is a downer but I think you're
getting the drift episode threes in cept
oh hi stint in use the themes of fate
and Rick trying to control it with an
arms race for the most randomly executed
controlled heist in the universe again
the idea here is that it's futile to
control your destiny even for an AI even
for the smartest guy programming AI it's
all wrapped up in a totally confusing a
plot the whole heist was all just Rick
trying to exert control over Morty's
future by getting him to turn down a
deal with Netflix yet another grab for
control by Rick that being said Netflix
if you have an opening in your schedule
now I would love to share with you my
super-secret goal of being a game show
host promise it won't be as obnoxiously
edited as the circle I really tried to
watch that show I know you really want
me to watch it you've been shoving it
down my recommended feed all the time
but man I watched like the first 10
minutes of it as it's rough
anyway episode 4 keeps the fatalistic
destiny defying party going by taking
every D&D fans fantasy and ruin in it
with dragon stuff doesn't seem like this
one would tie into
theme directly but it's no coincidence
that the show takes the high fantasy
themes of dragons and soul bonds and
heroic quests and then completely
undermines them all historically these
fantasy elements appear in stories that
have some kind of destiny drop the
jewelry into the volcano save the world
go on an epic journey because it is your
destiny you are the hero in our random
chaotic universe we use high fantasy as
a means of escape because those stories
are nice and linear and they make sense
kind of like the heist stories but no
one in Rick and Morty is the hero and
this isn't a D&D game where there's a
Dungeon Master guiding the story of your
character this is a real universe we are
best friend dragon that you were
contracted to have suddenly soul bonds
with a senior citizen and it ain't
pretty and it certainly isn't Destiny's
high fantasy more like grotesque reality
the TLDR here is your fantasies won't
save you and there's nothing romantic
about our story it's just kind of icky
and uncomfortable just like reality the
last lesson this season teaches us is in
Episode five which is less about trying
to control your own fate and more about
trying to control the fate of other
people or snakes snake people's sentient
snakes it's just a weird season all
right in an effort to control the fate
of an overpopulated snake planet morty
sends an earth snake to replace one he
accidentally killed in outer space in
the process more tea directly tampers
with the fate of an entire species he
changes their perceived destiny
unfortunately not only as fate not a
real thing he shouldn't tamper with
someone else's because it's gonna come
back and bite you literally over the
course of the episode we see that trying
to affect your future or worse go back
to your past to fix your future just
results in a big ol mess the universe is
too complicated to tamper with what's
supposed to happen or attempt to control
anyone else's future he can't do it even
if you're a sentient snake even if
you're Rick Sanchez at the end of our
half season we have a lot of open
questions but one thing we know for
certain is that we can't control the
answers there's no tricking your way
into controlling your fate because you
don't have one and on that uplifting
note we're left to piece together what
this lesson means for Rick the people in
his life and the rest of this season
everything around Rick the season is
telling him that there's no controlling
your place in the universe and frankly
his family is starting to tell him that
too directly morty refuses to blindly
follow rick in episode 1 by failing to
resurrect him not even listening to his
arguments before flying off in a
spaceship morty knows that rick will say
anything to control the situation
whether or not it's in
his best interests in short more tea
leaves Rick for dead in Episode one of
the season and isn't concerned about it
in the slightest he's also become bored
with adventures by the time that Rick
and Morty aren't grave-robbing in
Episode two and in Episode four Morty
has to be bribed with promises of a
dragon before going out with Rick robots
with you I said no his relationship with
Rick which has been the foundation of
this franchise is on the rocks he is
sick and tired of Rick's antics Morty's
not the only one either that Rick's
devoted daughter is also finally
standing up to Rick's manipulative
control over her and her family's life
starting as soon as episode 1 I don't
know if adventures fit into my son's
life I'm fine and again in episode 4 if
Morty ever gives up on a single dream it
better be because of his own
disillusionment this is a far cry from
the bet that we saw in season 1 who was
desperate to make sure that her father
stayed as a part of this family no
matter what even as recently a season 3
she still wanted him as a part of the
family but now she's over it she sees
Rick for who he really is and she's had
enough she's also stepping up in her own
life taking an active role in mothering
summer in episode 2 as part of her new
mantra a role that we have never seen
her take on before I'm in a mother you
until your 18th birthday even if I get
thrown in prison for non-consensual
mothering we also see Beth reconnecting
with Jerry criticizing him less making
choices that show that she's rebuilding
a stronger healthier relationship with
him which we all know is not making Rick
happy and though she may be
non-consensual II mothered summer ain't
takin any guff from Rick this season
either he offers to take her on
adventures and she couldn't care less
you want to go to boob world summer not
today this sucks
again a far cry from summer that we've
seen in previous seasons she's more
self-assured than we've ever seen her as
a pop culture taste maker or I will
tweet and you will be canceled and
demonstrates repeatedly that she don't
need no man or grandpa Rick to help her
make decisions
can you back then lastly we have Jerry
yeah even Jerry for crying out loud is
maybe the most pronounced arc in the
series become a stronger person less
influenced by Rick's constant demeaning
he gets reassurances from Beth that
they're together for the right reasons
in Episode two on the off chance that
you usually happen there's someone out
there I didn't use it
did you know we're all good dog in
episode 5 Jerry actively problem solves
even if it's in his own haphazard Jerry
s Quay refusing Rick's help to show Beth
that he can function on his own and not
giving in to Rick in situations where he
would have previously run away to a
Jerry daycare I won't let you die and I
won't tell Beth that you almost killed
yourself sounds like a win-win to me if
I survive it'll be without you and if I
die it'll be on your wha Merry Christmas
Wow long story short the family is
moving away from Rick four seasons in
the family finally recognizes that
Rick's tight fist of control isn't for
their own good he isn't some benevolent
genius force of the universe he's just a
lonely depressed drunk jerk and they're
all done tolerating it that's why
throughout these five episodes Rick is
either alone or finding a new companion
in most of them he's alone in episode 1
he's alone again searching for Tony's
friendship throughout episode 2 he's
reconnecting with old friends in episode
3 and he's spending his time with
Bartholomew the dragon in episode 4
completely disconnected from his family
proper as we head towards the back half
of the season my money is on the
storyline of Rick becoming more and more
isolated as his family loses interest in
his antics and his weird novelty because
the guy's just toxic
he's self-destructive he's a vortex of
sadness that will eventually get himself
and anyone near him at the time killed
they don't need him anymore Rick for his
part has abandoned his family in the
past but this time it looks like the
family will be the one abandoning him or
probably more likely Rickles see this
happening and just leave first so he can
get the last laugh and say he was the
one who chose to leave if the theme of
the season continues it seems likely to
end with Rick completely broken off from
the Smith family alone with no one and
with nowhere to go which in turn sets up
the next season as his quest for either
character growth or the hunt for a
replacement family so
say what you will about the comedy of
the season or the overall episode
structures they're not my favorite but
they're also probably not the worst no
one else episode four is probably the
worst but anyway the rest of them are
pretty darn good I love the toilet
episode but one thing that you cannot
say is that the season isn't forwarding
these characters their growth and their
story arms they've changed dramatically
throughout this season from where they
start in the first place and Rick as the
one who is slowest and most resistant to
change is looking like he's gonna get
left behind Rick and Morty has never one
to beat the message over your head too
hard which is one of the things I like
best about it but regardless of what
comes next
you can bet one thing I'll be there to
break it down selfishly selfish content
for the win
selfish content that at the end of the
day is still just a theory Oh film
theory and before I let you go one favor
I gotta ask of you YouTube lately has
been asking its users for satisfaction
surveys basically they'll see a video
that you've watched they'll throw it
back into your feet and be like hey on a
scale of 0 to 5 stars what did you think
of this video if you could rate us at a
high ranking that would be tremendous
that is seriously the single best thing
that you can do for this channel right
now because sometimes theories are
controversial whether or not people
agree with you they might like give you
a thumbs down or whatever but quality of
the video is still there right and so
rating at high quality video so that way
YouTube is like wow this is a channel
that produces high quality videos let's
spread it out onto the platform and not
hide it away from the rest of the world
that would be great so if you see one of
those surveys pop up I'm showing them on
screen right now they kind of looked
like this they tend to happen more often
on mobile devices but if you can rate us
a 5 star that would be tremendous thank
you so much for doing that and hey if
you haven't subscribed yet make sure you
subscribe because when Ricky Morty does
eventually come back later this year you
can bet that we'll be covering it this
is my last one for a while we got a lot
of other fun theories coming up but I
can't wait for the second half of season
make sure that you're there make sure
you hit that subscribe button thank you
so much for watching I've been Matt Pat
this has been real I'll see you next
week
you